well i hope it was a great passover
weekend for people who celebrate
um easter weekend etc
except for a lot of people it wasn't
good we had not one not two not three
not four not five
but ten mass shootings in the united
states over the easter weekend ten mass
shootings three of which were
prominent enough to make national news
but a total of ten different mass
shootings some
particularly horrible and it is yet
another reminder of this completely out
of control gun violence problem that
exists in the united states i'm going to
tell you a little bit about some of
these incidents so the guardian
reporting about three of these now some
of these were not
these terms are really crazy
some of these were not major enough mass
shootings
that they got national attention some
only got local attention uh the guardian
reporting u.s rocked by three separate
mass shootings over easter weekend
actually it was ten
two teenage boys killed in pittsburgh
in one of at least three shootings over
the weekend including two in south
carolina south carolina didn't just have
one easter mass shooting they had two
easter mass shootings
in pittsburgh two teenage boys killed
and eight others wounded after gunfire
erupted at a party in a short-term
rental home in pittsburgh early sunday
the other two shootings both in south
carolina left a total of 18 people with
bullet wounds once again reigniting
calls among advocates for meaningful gun
control legislation now remember at any
time if you're morbidly curious about
the sad state of gun violence in the
united states you can go to
gunviolencearchive.org and on that
website not only can you see a list of
all recent shootings
meaning mass shootings and and non-mass
shootings
you can also see
the mass shooting specifically and the
details and as you will see here uh
yesterday
easter sunday we had a shooting in
pittsburgh
miami
portland
furman south carolina sacramento
california and philadelphia pennsylvania
two mass shootings in pennsylvania
yesterday one in philly where four
people were injured and the one i
mentioned in pittsburgh were two were
killed and eight were injured on
saturday the day before easter we saw
mass shootings in syracuse new york
baltimore maryland columbia south
carolina and north las vegas nevada
and then on good friday we were lucky
enough to have only one mass shooting in
the united states in stockton california
now with any of these on gun violence
archive you can click on the view
incident or view source information so
for example if we look at miami
it tells us where the shooting took
place
and who the victims were gender age etc
and what the circumstances were this one
noting that it was a teen party a teen
party was the location of this shooting
this is absolutely insane and maybe the
most frustrating thing about this
is the resignation with which you know
it's this we we joke we're we haven't
tried anything yet and we're all out of
ideas
uh we've had all sorts of different
proposals and i'll be the first to tell
you i mean listen number one we have a
second amendment you're not just going
to ban guns that shouldn't even be what
the left tries to do because you're not
going to do it we have a second
amendment but we have so many things
that could be done
that would without a doubt reduce the
number of shooting deaths wouldn't
eliminate them of course you're always
going to have people who obtain guns
illegally that that's always the case
but
if there are fewer guns in the system
there are fewer guns which can be
obtained illegally and we saw after the
sandy hook shooting in connecticut
during barack obama's presidency
90 of the country said i mean listen
universal background checks a background
check for any gun transaction even
personal transactions if i sell a gun to
my friend
i should still
have some system where i can easily
run a required background check before i
sell them a gun maybe i don't know
everything about my friend limits on
ammunition
requirements in terms of insurance we
require insurance in most states
in order to drive a vehicle why wouldn't
we require insurance for owning guns
what about re-licensing not just you do
a weekend and get you then you get your
fid card and that's it but re-licensing
the way we do with driver's license i
mean there's so much low-hanging fruit
and the right has very successfully
framed the debate
as
any gun safety regulations should on
principle be opposed and are violations
of the second amendment now of course
that's not true
it's just not the case we have a second
amendment and the second amendment
remains in place but we have a really
sick situation and a lot of this as i've
spoken about before and this relates to
a lot of other issues we talk about
we have a broken culture in the united
states
too many people
see guns as a valid solution to problems
interpersonal problems
social problems
political problems we've talked about
that we also can't ignore
untreated and undiagnosed mental health
in the united states as well as lack of
access to mental health services as well
as stigma around getting treatment for
mental health it's not the way the right
likes to say
just a mental health problem of
individuals no
but it is part of it for sure and it's a
lot of different things together compare
that to a country like switzerland where
it's not you know the right loves to say
switzerland has tons of guns and they
don't have a mass shooting problem well
but hold on a second look at the
required training in in switzerland
look at the health care system in
switzerland look at the culture in
switzerland where it would be seen as
bonkers to consider using a firearm to
solve an interpersonal or political
problem in the united states we have an
entire political movement based around
no violence is valid as a way to solve
problems so when the right says it's
just mental health it's not but that's a
component culture is a component etc
think back to the kyle rittenhouse thing
as i've said before
it makes sense based on the facts that
he was acquitted but we said that from
the beginning based on the way
self-defense laws are written it makes
sense that he was acquitted but it is a
failure of parenting
it's a failure of gun culture it's a
failure of so many different things and
that is pretty unique to the united
states maybe it exists in some other
countries which we wouldn't typically
compare ourselves to i'm not sure
but it is it is quite a quite a
disturbing situation here it is a brand
new year maybe you have goals around
getting in better shape maybe cutting
back on sugar that's why you should
check out our long time sponsor magic
spoon magic spoon tastes exactly like
the delicious sweet breakfast cereals
you loved as a kid but magic spoon has
zero grams of sugar
14 grams of protein and only four net
carbs so it's perfect if you're doing
low carb or keto or if like me you just
try to limit your sugar intake you can
build your own variety pack with flavors
like cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman